We're back!
Hey!
Where's everyone?
Hello?
I thought that...
Weren't they supposed to be here?
Oh!
Hey you guys are back!
It's really you!
*Sam and Niko laughing*
Is anyone else here?
I thought everyone else is supposed to be back by now?
How long have you been here Jake?
um...
uh...
Since Christmas
*sigh*
Merry Christmas
Merry Christmas, Jake
Hey! You too, man!
And Happy New Year to you guys!
Its 2017
Welcome to the Sam and Niko channel
Yes, every year the Streamys happen
and every year the Streamys give us an award
It just so happens we got another visual effects award
to the hard
blood, sweat, and tears that Wren has put into these videos
Thanks, Wren
Thanks, Streamys
Let's go put it over here on this shelf
We don't dust them off that frequently,
so every January we come back and dust our awards
Yeah, this one's looking a little dirty
Yeah
Dude, much better
Look at that shine!
You missed that spot there
Cool
Good as new
All done!
I don't know about you guys,
but I spent a whole bunch of money on Christmas gifts this year
I got a really big family
So if it's cool with you guys,
I'd like to put a brand integration in this video
right now
Really? This one?
First one
First one of the year
Very first one of the year
You cool with that?
Season of giving
That'll work
You guys cool with that?
Cool
'Cause this video is brought to you by Lenovo,
and the Phab 2 Pro
So Lenovo reached out to us,
and asked if we'd be interested in
making a video about their phone
the Phab 2 Pro
What Lenovo does not know is that
a fan actually emailed us two months ago
about this phone
saying they were developing a film-making program
for this phone
using "Tango"
Now, what is "Tango"?
"Tango" is this piece of technology
that Google has been working on
that let's the phone track its position in 3D space
So this guy made a piece of software
that using that 3D tracking
would stabilize your video
better than anything else out there
that does artificial video stabilization
So I said: Yes,
Please send us a phone
because I want to check out that program
and see how it works
But before I do,
let me show you guys what "Tango" is
I don't think everybody quite gets this whole...
I've only seen one demo of this so far
Yeah
And even that was pretty impressive
*Niko laughs*
So on the back of this phone,
is a whole sweet of sensors here
cameras and I think a depth sensor
and a couple other things
that are constantly scanning the environment
But it's basically doing real-time motion tracking
For example,
You can pull a video
And have things overlayed
in your video
basically real-time visual effects
Wren, how do you like your pet?
Dude
Best pet
Way better than Obbi
*laughter*
Oh he likes it!
Oh!
Alright so we loaded up this program called "Holo"
which will let you take 3D scanned models
that are actual people or objects in a room
and place them in the environment
So this-
I think this will show off the tracking
better than anything else
There's a monkey over there
He's like...
Fo' getta 'bout it
*laughter*
Yeah
He's really funny
I bet...
He's playing you a song, man!
*laughter*
Alright
Oh my god!
*laughter*
That actually-
It works really- pretty good actually
I'm really suprised
Ah he's getting taller! He's growing!
He's growing!
He's like Hodor now!
*Wren laughing*
There he is, just chillin'
This guy,
This guy, right here
Has been with,
With me on every occasion
He's not good around guests
Dang!
The tracking is so good!
*Niko laughing*
Wow
*continues laughing*
My arms like, wha?
3 feet behind the zombie
Dang, that is pretty impressive though
So that's enough messing around
Hopefully you guys get the idea of how Tango works
It gives you this-
Whenever we do visual effects shots,
we need to put a fake element into a real shot
Enough games,
let's go apply this to some film-making
let's go test out that stabilization program
He's dancin'!
Scoot back!
So I fired up the app,
it's call "Cinamatic"
You can check it out on the Google Playstore
if you happen to have a "Tango" enabled device
like the Phab 2 Pro
It actually does the stabilization real-time
So now I'm recording in real-time,
it shows me the stablization
This is much more stable than any sort of like
"Gyroscope"-based stabilizer
like you get with "Hyperlapse"
'Cause it's getting an actual 3D track
of the environment
It's stabilizing off of that
So it's rock solid
it's like a steady cam'
It's pretty great
Sprint as fast as you can!
Dude, that's like a steady cam'
That's total steady cam' status
Woah
The virtual gimbal
You all jealous Nick?
My steady shots?
Yeah
Yeah, I'd be too
It's like...
Bad Boys 2 status, right here
Wait, do it one more time
Getting real-time stabilization
and real-time motion tracking data
and like a depth map out on your scene
This probably also,
it gives you anaglyphic
because it's scanning environment 3D
it gives you a 3D view
it also takes depth field if you want it too
HAHHH
*laughter*
Yup
That's so crazy
Thanks Lenovo, for sending us a Phab 2 Pro
If you guys are interested in learning
more about "Tango" and the technology...
...inside of this cellphone
I'll have links in the description below
Also,
if you are interested in getting a cellphone
that has "Tango" technology built into it...
...the Phab 2 Pro is the first phone on the market
with that tech
So, if that's something that suits your fantasy,
go check it out!
Thanks for watching, guys!
So if you guys thought this was cool,
and you want to see some more
Lenovo Phab 2 Pro videos
Just click on the end-screen here,
and you can see some more examples
of what this awesome technology can do
Thanks for watching